all right hello everyone welcome to
another design review in our season of
design reviews heading for Wolf language
version 14.
today it is discrete computation
and
what do we see here we so the back story
is that
um we in this release it's it's kind of
built up for the next release in a way
so in the next release we hope to have
full support for solid CAD
uh CAD geometry and that's based on
b splines or nerves
yeah so this release these are now
becoming geometry Primitives they
haven't up until this point been
geometric Primitives so you couldn't so
now you mean you mean I mean they've
been part of the region system haven't
they no they've not been part of the
region system they'd be part of the
graphic system sorry I see okay only the
graphic system yes
because you need to actually know things
about them in order to compute with them
okay let me make a general complaint
okay
I don't understand discretized region
boundary discretized region and so on
you know I made a piece of geometry and
I want to do stuff with it
I never understand when do I need to use
discretize region
so
well it depends on what you're gonna do
with it and so for in many cases you
don't need to do it yourself because we
automatically do it
so in some
if you have some horribly complicated
region
in order to actually compute with it you
often you typically need to discretize
it
and
only in some cases do you need to
discretize also let's say you have a
solid do you also need to discretize the
interior that's often called
triangulation and things like that
it's like for finite element you need
that
but for if you just want to see the
shape of a solid boundary discretized
region is typically sort of what you
want to do
so I'm going to make a complaint here I
mean we need to make this more automatic
because you know I'm not completely
clueless and like every time I try to do
this this is what we're working on
Stephen that that more of that is
getting automated
so I won't ever need to use discretized
region myself instead of true statement
well I mean you still probably have to
do it on occasion now but this that's
what we're going to do now yeah that's
the problem
yes but but that's what we're working on
to not have to do that
all right so we are standing most of the
method to actually automatically do that
for you I mean it's it's a
you know let me show you an example okay
this is um this is something I've been
working on with Brad
this is what you can see these are
polygons that are various kinds of
polygon Union things okay
um actually one complaint here which I
want to also Express
is those icons get very expensive when
there are lots of them like this
what can we do about that
because the icon is very low resolution
could we not discretize these things at
very low resolution and make the icon
hello yes so when you say discretize
what do you mean
by the child it's hard to hear you yeah
oh can you hear me now
somewhat yeah
okay
what I mean is this okay this icon is
Tiny right
it doesn't need high resolution
yet
so I'm asking you when you generate the
icon
are you doing it oh rasterizing not
discretizing you're talking about
probably rasterizing I don't even know
or approximating with a small number of
lines or something so that the cost of
producing all those icons is really low
am I making sense
yes yep we yeah we should be able to
because you are super hard to hear I'm
sorry the
sometimes Zoom seems to set
you know voice levels if you change
microphones it will get confused and I
think you maybe have to reset something
um
right
I think you're there but I can barely
hear you
um let's see is it better now
yes much better is it okay yeah I just I
think
um yes yes so we are we are working on
that we probably will have to find a way
I I think we try the rasterization it
doesn't work that great I mean they
still do the cost of earning the
rasterization for each polygon
but it's it's something we notice and we
are trying to fix I wonder if there's a
way to do very low resolution
rasterization
because that can't be that expensive
right
how important is it for you to have a
shape that shows what's underneath it
probably probably it is important it's
pretty nice nice yeah it is pretty nice
I agree
I mean this is really you know this is a
useful picture if this just said you
know yeah yeah how many blobs it's not
really no no it's it's clearly useful I
I
okay now the other issue here
is I think we've got pentagons being put
together here
um
and you know right now Boolean you know
region Union or whatever it is just
returns a symbolic it doesn't actually
do it
I'm gonna make it does it I mean that is
the representation of the Union
um
I guess you want the polygon at the end
it's what you mean I wanted I want a
single polygon I don't want a Boolean
whatever I mean these are polygons look
at it it's a polygon
foreign
I thought we were doing that for Paul
you know because we have closure within
polygons yeah we should that's why I say
we should probably look at the example
we work on it from 13th to actually make
all that possible so maybe there is a
well um
I mean in um
isn't it cool that things like that work
yes
um
now there is an issue actually here I
don't know if somebody's able to
actually find Brad we could ask in real
time
could somebody go find him please I can
ask to see if I can join you
um
okay I'm gonna come back to your agenda
until unless we get that because I think
I wouldn't mind hearing from you I mean
so Brad has definite examples where you
know it just returns Boolean
you know combination symbolically
without turning it into an without
resolving it into an actual polygon
he also has examples where
um you know it's got pentagons and so on
and the question of whether they whether
they
hold on can you pull a fresh copy of
that from the agenda because I did you
pull that from the from my website
something as well
yeah example are missing yeah the
examples are missing
well I I just pulled it from the from
the agenda link
I guess the same thing Roger sorry
mine looks exactly like Stevens okay I'm
copying send it by email send it by
email
unless it's too big
uh could you pull it again
okay
um
look it says it's 13 kilobytes I can't
believe that's big enough
no that doesn't seem right at all it's
the same size as it was before okay so
let me just say something here one
second okay that this I there's
something is wrong here on my end I
don't know what it is yet I'll see okay
oh my gosh layered graph that's gonna
change my life sort of
the number of times I've had to type
graph layout Arrow layer Digraph
embedding is ridiculously large
hmm it's regarding that that's really
cool
I want to see examples of these what
does layered graph 3D do
um so we have this 3D version right so
the layer graph is today
right so this is the 3D version okay now
Stephen could you pull it
it's my that was my bad I actually so
the same location yes
I'm sorry it's still the same size
13 kilobytes I mean look just send it by
email please
it'll take a while I'll do it well
send us a link somehow
you want me to send that yeah send it
bye Brad here
hi there we're talking about
um geometry and region
you had an example
of where
we couldn't get the actual raw polygon
out all we could get was
the you know bullion combination
symbolically what is that example
uh it's on the function repository page
for this
planar polygon fragmentation thing
okay
I think it's sorry it tells you
tells you were going to say you say
you're not intending to do that is that
correct Charles that it might happen in
a corner case or something or what
um yeah it's probably a corner case and
um I need to see the example okay where
is it Brad uh look under properties and
relations
okay see this
okay this I don't get it
region Union okay let's just run it
okay
is that what you expect Charles
I know should probably give can you
apply any front of the polygon probably
in front of which part of the polygon
given that one in your any of them so
Justin maricia and uh coordinate let's
see what happened
aha
we will fix that it's one of those
decisions where we try to do exact and
maybe the exact method fail and then we
don't recover correctly so okay
so then
if I can just if I can just say
something that was the purpose of this
wfr is getting about
halfway through the whole problem of
doing the poly set operations for
polygons and the the only part that's
really left is like
um this algorithm here just kind of
makes pieces and then for the last
you'll kind of do it exactly is that
right Brad
yes yeah
because if it's just a polygon with
linear edges then you know you can
always solve those intersection points
pretty easily except that you have that
problem with with Max extra Precision
didn't you yeah
um the ultimately the most difficult
part of this whole thing turns out to be
the undecidability of zero testing
and yeah go ahead and I didn't I just
tried to make this thing run at machine
precision and but still be able to uh
because what I decided for the zero
testing is probably in the end all the
zero testing is going to be have to be
numerical to some set okay but but I
just want to know from Charles and Roger
is this is what Brad has done here is
this a useful extension to what you
already have
is you know we do the end here it was
just to check that the result will work
in principle we should be able to do
that exactly right okay but that's what
Brad just spent a bunch of effort on so
maybe you can make use of what he did
but or do you think we already have we
already have the module internally and
we do that anymore more clever way by
using numerical approximation to zoom
down to the number of I mean where do we
actually need to compute the
intersections and then for me to recover
or the exact
so wait a second so so is it the case
that the fact that this okay let me just
understand the flow here the fact that
this didn't work is a bug or it's okay
but so you claim that absent the bug you
will be able to do all the things that
Brad is doing here is that true
um I don't know what he's doing but we
should be able to do the original Union
exactly
okay Brad are you doing things other
than region Union here
um well we're not even quite doing
region Union here but what we're aiming
for in the end is region Union region
intersection region difference all of
those things working on polygons and
getting the exact coordinate values
whenever they need to okay but but
Charles is claiming that he thinks he's
doing that except for bugs well I'm am I
playing around with this functionality
I've not seen it I've not seen very many
cases where it it goes through
okay fine all right well look so I mean
Charles has a driver for additional
things that should work because browse
managed to get some additional things to
work
and I think you guys should talk about
it
and um you know it may turn out that
what Charles has done
is you know will
kind of cover everything Brad has done
when the bugs are removed or not as the
case may be but let's find out that seem
reasonable
so
um but I just want to understand in in
Charles's case
are you going to run into max extra
Precision type type nonsense when you
try and do the exact computations
um well I'm not sure where the max this
type Precision is happening so it means
essentially this is a line This aligned
line intersection right pretty much
assuming that the polygon is
canonicalized right and there is no self
intersection in the polygon and all
those special cases
what was the case where you ran into
this yeah like um let's say that you
have
well in the in the multi-way example
that Steven's got in the background
there what happened was that especially
with the pentagons
is that we were transforming the
pentagons through space and trying to
get them to line up edge to edge
and then
um we just want to get the region Union
combining these two adjacent pentagons
like you can see it right there
but that process is gonna involve
identifying that uh two of those
vertices on two different pentagons are
the same thing but you can get symbolic
as soon as you're doing rotation
matrices and translations you can get
symbolic swell pretty easily and the max
extra Precision stuff comes out a lot
when you have these squared of nested
square roots square root of fives
whatever okay so that's because the
rotation Matrix and the Pentagon
coordinates involve algebraic numbers
basically yeah is the standards the road
testing issue right so yeah it's a
standard zero testing
yeah I know but that's why I'm asking
you is that something you have seen in
your
stuff because it seems like it's a
generic thing that's going to happen
but it depends on if you use possible
zero queue it doesn't happen
well eventually we will still fail right
I mean there is it will fail but it will
not issue the message what
yeah so what I was thinking for the
design of the the
the final design is that there would be
something like possible zero q but and
maybe the user can pass in a working
Precision goal that
um tells the function how rigorously it
should test which is which Charles could
potentially do as well for I mean you're
not doing that for region Union at this
time are you
well we are using different other
techniques in geometrically to resolve
those those Corner cases right it's
similar to what we have introduced you
know uh you know positively oriented or
negative oriented on left or right of a
line
to resolve those um
testing issue in Geometry so there's
those different Technique we we use
behind the scene but what I'm trying to
get at is in the end you're not going to
have a zero testing problem or you are
going to have a zero testing problem
do you think that you're going to never
need to worry about zero testing
in the case of a line I believe you will
not have to worry about it
okay
I think you and Brad should meet up and
you should look at this and maybe maybe
maybe there's a way to resolve what Brad
is doing or maybe Brad is looking at a
case that hasn't been considered yet
um all right because I really think the
zero testing issue is unavoidable
okay but Charles thinks there might be
some I don't understand Charles's claim
that it is avoidable
um
I don't understand how you know whether
the polygon closes there or has a seam
there
unless you have some convention that
causes you to just say no I don't I just
don't understand how do you how do you
avoid how do you know that those two
points are actually coincident
yeah that's the issue so directly in the
standard way right it's obviously is the
road testing but usually it's depends of
how you build you know the algorithm you
run in Geometry works right which at the
end to resolve those issues you pretty
much always have to figure out if you
have a line and your point is on the
left or the line on the right of the
line
right so we reformally the problem
completely differently and in those case
you may avoid it
I see but I mean the case of whether the
whether the two points like this these
pentagons right is there a gap between
these two pentagons or not doesn't that
require zero testing
yes
but you can use the fact that if you
build the two line which are parallel if
maybe that give you an additional
information instead of just comparing
to point you pretty much have four
points which can give you enough
information
right but yeah there's always the case
that you can build case where you know
it may happen okay
all right apparently these kinds of
problems are pervasive and in the 1980s
absolutely yeah
geometry yes it's almost humorously bad
I know yes you know so there is layers
and layers in our geometry engine that
deals with this at various levels I know
I know I know I know I know
um all right
um
the uh
okay I'm I'm also seeing a um
complaint from Sandra on our live stream
that that uh this this stuff is nice but
slow and it gives an example here I'm
going to cut this down to 100 because
I'm worried that it's going to take too
long no that's okay
um
maybe he's referring to the rendering
time
uh yeah
um I think we put back to the rendering
time then
um okay let's continue with the rest of
the agenda and I think Brad if you if
you um I don't think you're relevant for
the rest of the agenda if you want to
depart or not as the case may be
again we now have examples here okay
bezier curve
oh we can compute the arc length of the
bezier Curve
that's cool
it's a piecewise polynomial
yeah I guess that's right
um
okay now I'm just I'm you know I'm still
attacking the screen let me make another
comment okay
you know we know there are these
workflows region Union of things that
you know the the Brad example here right
what are you doing to inventory
you know in other words we have certain
principles like you should never need to
use discretizing region
right you should never in accept in
corner cases
you know nobody should need to know
about that function right so
so what we've done is that basically
we've given up an exact computation
if we insisted on like we do in the rest
of the system if you call something we
don't have a parallel set of n functions
and S functions yep
um so we have one set of functions if we
insisted if we always went exact and
hung we'll return unevaluated and nobody
would like it exactly
so what we've done is that they all have
a working Precision option
okay which is effectively an auto
discretization you know option the
setting is automatic is that a new plan
or as well no it's a couple of years old
but we've we haven't we sort of steadily
and and steadily flowing it in at more
and more places because it takes work
to get it right
and and you you can set that work in
Precision to Infinity in which case you
will insist you will basically opt into
exact computation otherwise the
automatic plan is that it attempts given
exact input it attempts to do exact
computation if we have
such algorithms and then after a certain
time it will give up and it will record
exactly what I was going to suggest yeah
yeah
now my only question there is
how long is the time
200 milliseconds or something or how
long is it is it human imperceptible
times or not
Charles
you mean when we attempt to do the exact
or not how long do we give the exact
yeah before we sort of before we Punt
and go to
approximation
well we built it in different layer
right I mean so we have first sample
case where we know it you know the exact
method so we go with that as long as we
know the activity will work yeah so
there's a class of problems for which we
know we have input completeness right
yep
exact will work quickly or exact will
work okay I've got a suggestion okay
sorry do we just know that it will work
or we know it will work quickly we know
that it will work it will work quickly
yes yeah we have lots of cases where
we've derived pneumatics effectively
which are quick and scalable and
symbolic
okay so hold on they're different cases
number one
we know it will work and we know it will
work quickly number two is there a case
where we know it will work but it might
be slow
or does that is there no such case
well like
well we we went a little bit differently
right so we know that you will work and
you work quickly so we have the method
and essentially what we build then is a
fallback General method
like what what do you mean a general
method that is exact or is inexact
so
when I say General methods so the
general method is inexact which is kind
of the discretized now
and also we have a general method where
we know okay it exact
but you know let's suppose we know that
we call an expensive function has
anything you know integrate for example
then we put a time constraint which
roughly in most of the time is about two
seconds
and then we fail and then we default to
the numerical method
okay can I make a suggestion okay
in the case where we're trying this
exact thing
why not have a progress monitor that
comes up
saying trying exact computation
and it could even say have some words in
it
that basically you know even by saying
trying exact computation that's a clue
to people if you don't want to take that
extra time go look in the documentation
you can probably avoid this
do you see what I'm saying
um yes we can start to okay you know add
because monito has an option for most of
them
but I would say a very specific thing I
mean I just had this idea but I think
it's a decent idea and I think it's an
idea that we could use in a bunch of
other functions because you know putting
up a progress monitor which is going to
go away when the computation is finished
is a very low risk thing to do in my
view
I mean we haven't at least in this case
propagated because there is also the
cost of actually estimating
why the progress of the the method that
was happening right I'm a progress
monitor doesn't have to show progress
it is that's what I was just saying what
I was saying that don't worry about
assessing amount of progress all the
progress monitor well some of them just
established steps you know I'm doing
this and then I'm doing that yeah it
doesn't say how much it accounts for how
much time has elapsed
yeah I can do that right but but also
more important it would just say
attempting symbolic you know exact
symbolic computation
okay so generic right enough just
information instead of more timing done
okay yeah right just that just that
attempting exact symbolic computation
and you look at that and you see I've
got a hundred of these things going on
it's taking five seconds doing each of
these this is crazy let me go look at
the documentation and find out how to
tell it's not even tried to do that
see what I'm saying I I'm kind of
thinking that that might be an
interesting thing to do in other places
like I don't know eigenvalues or
something where it's trying to do an
exact thing and it's just like takes
forever
and you know that's actually Stephen so
so so we're slowly
uh attempting to migrate we haven't done
it in a big scale but this is kind of
like our
um would you call it
um lab if you like where we're because
there's no choice for geometry no
yes I get it but what I'm
suggesting is a general Paradigm but
yeah but doing this which will make it
cheaper to decide to do it yes
because if if it says attempting
symbolic thing
um
you know
in fact the way to do it here's my
suggestion okay
um
this is actually a decent idea okay so
attempting symbolic exact symbolic thing
okay
failing over to an exact computation in
five four three two one seconds
you see what I'm saying
yeah why is that useful that's useful
because it tells one it might be
possible to do it symbolically
and if you wanted that go look at the
documentation and see how to do that
you see what I'm saying sure rather than
because because otherwise what's going
to happen is
it's it's going to be very obscure it
says it's trying to do the symbolic
computation it's going to give a result
and it's like where the hell did that
come from
and and the fact that it says failing
over in five four three two one seconds
already gives you the idea that there is
a timeout number
yeah I like this idea I think this idea
could be done very generally and it
would solve the problem that we've had
for for decades where people say oh I
was doing eigenvalues and your system is
is you know 80 000 times slower than
this little you know trivial numerical
thing that I wrote
yeah I
yeah no I I we've had this come up in
many areas in when we do symbolic
statistics for instance you know
probability
well I think this is a good General
solution I mean you basically just have
a countdown in the progress monitor you
have a countdown saying what's happening
and then you fail over and we we pick a
number and uh you know you're able to
put you know we need some general option
name
uh you know we have one in simplify
right in full simplify we have time
constraint don't we
remember what that is no but I remember
we have one
time constraint
means I haven't used it for a while
that function that that capability no I
agree I haven't used that for a while
either
I mean basically either full simplified
works or it doesn't and you you don't
you know you want the defaults so
the fact that this default is infinity
is interesting
and again you know I mean what I'm
suggesting is introduce this time
constraint thing or maybe some slightly
more refined version of this
with its progress monitor
anyway okay let's continue I really like
this idea I really like it I think it's
going to solve a bunch of problems
okay
okay I don't want to see any of these
boundary discreet as region things why
am I seeing that why are you even
showing that I don't understand if I
just say region of this why doesn't this
just work
that's actually
so if you look at the difference that's
actually the Improvement we are adding
in this release that we are generating
sharp corners
whatever is happening it should happen
just with region I shouldn't have to say
boundary discretize region right right
we agree yes yes okay fine okay so
that's very cool that you can do that
how are you doing that
um
so the thing is that when you're trying
to discretize like in in like a region
plot 3D or something like that the
marching cubes style method will not be
able to get sharp Bridges right okay so
what you have to do is to discretize the
various pieces and then do you know
Boolean operations
what is this
probably in I don't know that was the
example for uh import for step
unfortunately is not fully plugged in so
the example doesn't run
yep thanks
um
okay
we need to look at here I mean this is
this looks cool but I don't know
uh
yeah there is no particular design
issues
fine but it's still feature other than
the fact that we all agree that
discretized region should never be
needed
except when you want to convert your
region into a mesh yes
fine
I mean it's like a little bit like
saying that n is never needed
um fine yeah I get it I get it but I
mean in um
what are the related things here okay
what is mesh region as compared to
discrete eyes region
is a region representation of the is a
mesh representation of the region okay
that's fine yeah it's it's a type of
region
piecewise linear
that is a converter
and that
had
additional goals not yet fully
implemented because Graphics is a
container of a soup
yeah and you need to be able to search
in that soup
to find what it is that you want
and so that's not as fully developed yet
as it as it will be and the issue is
what the certain Graphics functions we
can't successfully discretize with
discretized Graphics or what no but
let's say that you only wanted the red
Parts yeah okay that that's the thing I
was imagining and I also I don't
understand whether you can you know
whether regions can never have red
annotation can regions have annotation
like graphs
yes
so you could carry red or Texture as an
annotation
um yes
we it's a work in progress but you can
pretty much wrap it with you know
styling and all the stuff I see and then
when the region display happens it will
by default use the styling is that true
yes you should
can I see an example
um
um like for example if I do here
if I go here and I say
style of the ball
red
whoops
now I'm very
I mean it's I mean so current So
currently we you know we started to add
those annotation and information just
for the original Hopper
so in principle if you do region of
um
if this can be due to a disk bed you
should get the D Squared
but look you've got to make these things
all work I mean something like this has
got this is this is not okay so you're
saying region of style
of disk comma red
okay that worked but for some absolutely
mysterious reason the other thing didn't
work here
well not personally Reason by default we
make sure that the input is a region
right so style of a ball is not a region
right but those are the enhancement we
hope progressively to start to get
rapper you know in most of the functions
well I don't understand I understand it
doesn't matter region intersection okay
it's very naive of region intersection
to insist that the thing is on its face
I mean it reminds me of these um you
know
cd8 positive cells and things in the
body on its face on its boundary on its
you know it is visibly a such and such
cell
so to speak right that shouldn't be
necessary maybe that's what you're
saying region intersection should be
able to discover that this is in fact a
region even though it was wrapped in
something different
simply we can we can't do that but we
agree that that's the objective right
sure
is there any issue about that objective
um no I mean we haven't emphasized that
first because region operation
intersection is an operation right so
usually
we assume that the impulse should be a
wager but we can okay but we just didn't
assume that I mean you know given that
we're dealing with annotation this is
the same mistake we keep on making right
once you introduce an idea like I would
never you know after this doesn't work I
would never bother to try this
see what I'm saying
no unless it's uniform people just
assume it isn't going to work
no no I definitely agree but what I
meant is you know are we expecting
somebody to type you know area style
ball red sorry am I internet connection
are you back yep
okay yes we're expecting them to type I
mean okay we're expecting okay so let me
explain why they might type that they
won't type it it will be the output of
something completely different
that's what I'm saying yep so and I want
it to just work in the same way that
this just works
right I mean here I'm sure if I ask for
this it will
you know tell me it's it's PI right even
though it's red it doesn't make a red
pie there
it doesn't care but it's got to work in
general not not okay we get the point
yep all right let's let's move on let's
move on let's move on
um
wait Matt did I get the examples yes
this is the Roman examples
okay
oh joy this is great okay let me
complain about
um two things
one is aspect ratios of some of these
graphs
what is determining them because they
were way too high in some of the things
I was doing
and it didn't care about aspect ratio if
I changed aspect for sure it didn't pay
attention to it
did you understand what I'm saying
um
um yes
um so one is that we as long as I
remember we don't set up the aspect
ratio
and just less the graphic by default is
the aspect ratio
no I mean the graph determined its
aspect ratio
I I know that
um
see if I can find one for you
well I don't know if I can find one
um
they've all been fixed now so
uh
a boy I mean there's a lot of
complicated code here and I'm going to
show I can show you what the graph
roughly looks like but I don't think you
know there's a graph
um
like this
where it was just taller than it should
have been and and you know it had to be
manually modified and when one gave it
to do you think it should pay attention
to an aspect ratio specification or not
um
personally I think he shouldn't because
to really get the white aspect ratio we
need to compute this you need to
actually know the size of the vertices
right and the only way is to do a pass
to the front end render them
and then be able to estimate the white
aspect ratio
yes so
as long as you all agree that there is a
cause to it
um that's fine
I mean I mean yes in
look if you have to render I mean it's
like with performance goal error quality
or something we should do it
okay yeah probably for performance goals
performance goal goes to Quality you
should probably do it let's do it
right
see these kinds of things it drives me
crazy because I didn't know this that
we're just ignoring the aspect ratio
because we think it's too expensive to
do the computation I had no idea
and it's like how would I ever know that
you know to me it's just a bug that
doesn't work
I'm making sense
yes
but I don't understand if the aspect
ratios just passed along to the
corresponding graphic it would respect
it
no it doesn't it it does things like it
it makes the um you know circular
uh nodes of a graph elliptical and weird
stuff like that yeah that's what
Graphics does that's not the right thing
it's not the right thing oh
right we want an aspect ratio that's the
whole point we want I mean Graphics
doesn't well okay Graphics does do that
doesn't it for a disk
yeah this is actually what Graphics does
okay so hold on hold on so what I'm
saying is we want the overall okay so
what are other examples of something
where we want
the aspect ratio not force changed but
it's because a graph doesn't have
geometric information in it we could
imagine changing the aspect Joe show
without sort of
you know distorting the individual
elements right
um you see what I'm saying we can change
the aspect ratio of this graph by just
doing this
okay
and that's what I want it to do
correctly automatically if I say take
this graph right if I say this and I say
graph
of this
aspect ratio
Arrow one for example
oh whatever I mean this is some more
complicated thing
um
I don't know what that did there okay
it's complaint number one complaint
number two arrows break off their
arrowheads when you resize a graph are
you aware of that is Sue Charles
um I saw the bug you file
um
go ahead
I saw the buggy file and but I mean it's
um you know it's something which I
should probably discuss with you so in
the
um for the apple head or such
right the arrow the arrowhead breaks off
it's clearly wrong the other thing that
happened is which I I think we sent in
Nick probably sent in this bug report we
had these very vertical things but this
one may have been an example and as you
resize it the arrows suddenly oh look
look at that the arrows just sort of
broke off there the arrows suddenly get
you know absolutely huge right so you
see that the arrows broke there
see that
yeah so let's see
you're fine but something is wrong
your example from Nick it's it's more on
the graph side where we didn't estimate
correctly the size of the arrowhead
okay fine fine
okay so you can fix it it's just a
corner case
all right
well this is great so layered graph is
okay now what happens
if the graph
that has a root node right
um assumes a root node
yes
how do you compute a root node first um
Center
so I picked one around
is that correct
what did it do in that case
we we compute the graph center from the
graph Center a complete graph doesn't
have a graph Center does it
I guess probably pick the first one or
such
okay
but you should document what it actually
does
now I do think how do I give a different
root note here
um I think this second argument should
be the root okay that's what I was
assuming but okay so let's try taking I
mean this graph I know these are very
symmetric these are very very
symmetrical graphs but but I mean so
this will just look the same if I say
four
really why does that look different
isn't this a Vertex transitive graph
um well it's
we we cannot guarantee that even for the
same graph when you compute the layout
there won't be some I won't say
numerical error but some change in the
layout
so this is saying dominant vertex at
position whatever so if I say four arrow
top
and if I say four arrow left
lovely
this will be super useful thank you
these are this a million times
um
now I mean if I say lead graph 3D
is that a new algorithm that we've never
had before layered graph3d no
uh
we added it to
layer graph plot 3D right
yes when we released after a couple of
release ago
why is it so flat
I mean it's what something that happens
from time to time it just sort of punts
on being 3D
maybe there's nothing you can do in this
case
yes well at least
I should be using the aircraft
ready to use that actually and um
I think it like some of the things that
we looked at like food webs and so on
look really nice
in these
uh the 3D layers
well I think I've got a lot of examples
oh boy and you've got you've got
hyperbolic as well
wow
okay can I try if I say carry tree
um
50 or something
and now let me try doing
graph layout Arrow hyperbolic embedding
and disclaimer there's still some issue
we need to we are resolving so it may
not be perfectly what you expect
okay let's go to those
that looks what I would expect well no
there's a bug yes those are the case we
are trying to trace down why it's
happening
okay
and obviously the the um node sizes are
too big
but when you say hyperbolic layout is it
is it I mean the point array disc and
things like that have a circular
boundary but is that a necessary feature
of rendering hyperbolic space
I I'm just I mean in other words the
mapping onto a disk is that is that
generic somehow or could you render
hyperbolic space in a different sort of
uh mapping to something different
um it could be different but essentially
what we rely on this essentially spring
electrical embedding but we rely on
essentially be able to find a white
projection which give you the tangent
space on the you know distance and angle
correctly so we could probably do
hyperbolic in 3D it would render into a
ball
like
yeah we could give any
you know a manifold surface type thing
as long as you have the right tangent
information and then we do the
projection every time we do the spring
electrical
I think it'd be nice to the 3D version
of this although it might be hard to see
because it might be that you'll that it
always has you know coating on the edges
so to speak right
if it's a growing tree yeah it might be
nodes all the way around right I mean
it's worth trying
and then you know it might be the only
thing I I don't even know whether it
would look reasonable
sounds like a thing to okay
Prototype all right good stuff
um
yes good because that's something we
didn't didn't have
Sandra is commenting that layered graph
plot isn't it the same as this it is
more or less the same except this is
just with a graph
I mean I assume if we say let go of plot
yeah I mean we should be retiring graph
plot wow it's exactly the same
as we can see because it's purple
are useful right because we want the
generated graphics
but it's also kind of the way out when
you have a really large graph right and
in most of the case we don't want you
know we generate the blob
yeah instead of actually handling I know
I know although I'm not totally certain
that that's the right design approach
in other words it's it's not obvious
with our more interactive way of
handling things nowadays it's not
obvious that that blob shouldn't just
have an attached You Know Tab that
allows you just like just like the um
you know why isn't it just like a too
big output
you see what I'm saying
yes
to force a layout no it's not good yep
yeah we can we can add that so you can
just press on it and then it falls the
layout right right I mean but in other
words the graphic Motif will be similar
to the
the too big
I mean honestly that would be a good you
know fallback for many of these things
when the graphic gets you know
until when we think it's going to be too
costly to render is you render it as
something you know because just like why
are we why are we doing what we do if
you say you know range of a million you
know we're doing that because we think
it's going to be too expensive to you
know split that out into the notebook
right so we turn it instead into this
you know into our standard you know
you know we turn it into this right
because it's too big to split into the
notebook but we should be able to do
exactly the same thing with like a graph
that's too big probably with the same
graphic design
am I making sense
yes yep
the only difference is this is always
top level so if I have a list of two
ranges I'll just get a single one of
these blobs
whereas with graphs you might very well
want you know if you have a list of
graphs you might want one per graph
do you understand what I'm saying yes
okay
let's look at other things here
um well it's not yet completed it's just
it's still in in progress and you don't
have any
so you probably want to look at the
table of contents maybe that's the
others I just looked at two random
chapters
I mean it's listed but it's not yet
fully completed so
the heck is a cohesive group
social network analysis
so like a clan or a k-clan
your community yeah
um
you know somebody should at least look
through the endless uses of graphs that
I've had in the last few years
because
this seems a lot like you know
what graphs were used for 10 years ago
type thing
much of which is there still used for
today I mean these kinds of things are
are useful are good
I would recommend taking a look
and I think you'll find a bunch of um
for example
uh
let's see
I mean there's just tons and tons of
tons
which is a tribute to the whole um uh
Charles Enterprise here
but I mean you know you go and look at
this there's tons and tons of graphs
here
and and many of which the things one's
doing with them are a little different
than this kind of story am I making
sense it's not social network analysis
you know these are game graphs in this
case right
yep
and and there's a lot of stuff here
where but also just just so you know
we're not intending to put like a we
want more books rather than like a big
encyclopedia type
that's fine but I'm telling you I think
you've got to modernize what you're
talking about with graphs and networks
okay
sorry yeah go ahead so what I mean is so
the I mean the idea is that you know
it's first and then
book for you know anybody who wants to
learn the kapha network and probably at
the last section is where we try to have
social network and sorcery you know you
know we can probably add add more look
the fact is something like the game
graph of tic-tac-toe is a pretty easy to
understand what it's supposed to be
but it's an example of a graph that gets
big
and I mean many of these graphs that I
have it's very easy to understand what
they are and they get big
and then things happen with big graphs
that are not you know you can have a big
graft that if somebody went out and
measured what Beetle eats what Beetle
wherever it is right but these are
graphs that get big you know of natural
causes so to speak well the Beatles are
probably natural causes too but again
you know it's kind of like what do you
do with a graph like this how do you how
do you take subsections out of it how do
you how do you illustrate you know
you know how do you have nodes that have
things how do you deal with flow through
graphs like this those kinds of
questions right how do you I don't know
what this is this is some yeah this is a
strategy of
um for Tic-tac-toe games
okay this is all and this is all God you
know paths and graphs but it's all the
same type of thing
but it's just like
I think there's a yeah somebody should
take a look through there's tons of
graph related things here
um
okay I would I would recommend really
just look at the last four years or so
actually more than that I mean I'll give
you another example here of um you know
I'll give you another example that
that's um
uh
this one it's another good example of um
you know
that's the citation network of Euclid
okay it's a pretty nice data set because
it's quite you know it's 465 Dirhams
it's not that big but then here there's
a lot of stuff like your Dominator thing
is a story here
right I mean the whole point is and then
this type of thing like you can do the
same type of analysis that I did here
for I don't know the US code or endless
other things but it's not social
networks which is kind of a passe kind
of analysis right
it's like it's a it's a new Fresh not
very hard to understand what the point
is you know it's not that new I mean
people have been doing this as a matter
of fact you know what in terms of that's
that's the theorem network of Euclid
right
and you can compute all kinds of things
from that
um
but just to prove that there's nothing
new Under the Sun the thing that
actually
um
Don knuth pointed me to this is oh
actually he didn't have a network this
is the uh dependency graph of the
theorems in Euclid written out by a
certain Thomas Harriet
who also wrote a brief and true report
of the Newfound land of Virginia
hmm
in 1585.
just to make sure we know there's
nothing new Under the Sun
um I just thought that was that was kind
of cute he made some mistakes but but
that's that's the you know that he could
have drawn that as a graph he didn't
um
okay in any case I'm just I'm telling
you there's a lot of stuff here that is
you know
graphs I mean that's one that comes
that's another thing you should do
that's one that comes directly from our
uh
um from our data and you can also do
that from from a lot of stuff from our
built-in data
yeah this you need to not be looking
backwards to what people wrote in golf
and network books 20 years ago you need
to you know we've got a lot of good new
more material somebody should look
through the community as well there's
probably a lot of stuff there as well
you know modernize please
please no definitely we'll do that
all right
this is the thing I've been asking for
for a long time
did you run this or should I run them
now
you can run them
what on Earth is the thing that gets
wrapped around the sphere like that oh
it's it's there
really
so what projection is that
um spherical
detection
what
detection mapping is a spherical
projection no I understand that but I
must go go to the page reference page
and there are illustrations that explain
each of the projections the standard
predictions okay but I'm understanding
that doesn't look like the Earth
that looks like the Milky Way It Is yeah
you have you have two texture
projections going on there's this Earth
and there's a cylindrical
equidistant texture
let's see and this is also using there
are two spherical projections
right so where's the texture for the
Earth or you didn't give that because
it's there it's coming from a an entity
entity
oh I see I see I see that was what was
confusing me
but I do want to see the page
okay that looks much more familiar thank
you yeah and that's a cylindrical
equidistant yeah whatever yeah yeah
right right I know what that is I mean
that's that's unsurprising this was the
surprising part
um okay texture new
this is very useful
it's all very useful
and how does this relate to what people
are doing with 3D cameras and so on
like if I take my 3D camera
and um what is it going to produce is it
going to produce one of these
what's a 3D camera
well like I have this thing what's it
called I think what's called I haven't
used it I have to admit there was a
thing
um
yeah here we go
this um
this thing for instance okay I have one
of these
what does it what does it take
but you hold it up and it's
you know I mean you you explain it to us
well I don't know I mean it I've had
this thing for years so one thing that
you can
go ahead
I think that I mean in terms of
explaining use cases and so on there are
many use cases now go down the list the
application section should have a long
list of them
um
and but for instance you could take a
camera and you just spin around like an
ax axis around you right you basically
take a cylinder view of the world yeah
like apple has a way of doing that right
it takes a bunch of pictures and
stitches them together right
panoramic view or something yes why
there is you know spherical view right
or Skybox
okay but what I'm asking is these these
things well if you extract from an
iPhone or something
the panoramic view what is this what is
the the bag of pixels
that it puts into your photo album
or do we not care because it's doing all
the processing
yeah but what I try I mean I had it you
know I just took a pan marked view of it
of my office and
you do essentially I get an image right
so and you know I try to apply it to our
cylindrical
projection new cylinder which actually
did work the only thing I didn't add it
here is because the the roof was not
correct and doesn't look correctly so I
haven't really investigated down
you know all the data okay that's that's
as far as I know
so how did it how did it determine in
this in this version here
this texture
so right now there's not yet automatic
texturing so the polygon there have a
Vertex texture called in it embedded
Amendment this bunny has many many
polygons in it yeah
so how's my bunny
I don't understand how did its ear
texture I mean how does the how the
relative orientation someone or
somewhere there was texture coordinates
for for every vertex has vertex texture
coordinates there are coordinates into
the texture
image
okay
but so
so I mean I don't understand the
spiritual try a bunch of these okay just
let's just go through a bunch of them to
begin with at least get some more
context
that's a big image though
okay I think I saw this one before now
so this is just for producing the first
example in Skybox image to pack the
function Repository
it's really hard for me to make the
rotation controller work in a useful way
here
why is the rotation controller so
I think because if you open that I think
we put it Globe the quotation if you
open the
yeah but I mean what what rotation
controller would be sensible
so it is not even
yeah look I cannot use this thing this
thing is just sort of randomly
floating around what I mean clearly
presumably this should not be a turn
upside down rotation controller
why it should be a globe one
um a concerned since someone I don't
know where I put that examples yeah the
controller rotation controller here is
wrong so sure but why did that happen I
mean is that happening because graphics
3D it's happening because graphics 3D
generically has a turn upside down
rotation controller doesn't it yes
so how would we know
okay that's that's lovely it's marbled
cube of vertex texture coordinates Arrow
cubic what does that mean
so a lot of our if I have a dodecahedron
there
would Excel look at the illustration on
to the right that just tells you
where the texture is used and how it's
projected on I understand okay so for
the dodecahedron when I use the cubic
texture what is it actually doing here
it's using that cubic texture projection
that you see on the right
so I see so it's it's going into the
tattoo the the dodecahedral faces well
let me try tetrahedron here for example
actually let me try sphere sphere here
why didn't that work
oh I mean the uses here we are still
implementing several of those so
okay so that's a bug
but what should it do
it it
is
you see it like it's a big tube outside
of your I know I know I know okay and
it's it's it's it's projecting in like
it just has lights coming in from the
side of a cube right yep yes
and so it should distort in this case I
don't understand why it isn't distorting
that because the thing is not orthogonal
to the incoming light I mean is are
there lights in Infinity on all the
sides
then someone's saying are you parallel
projecting
into the cube
yes for the cube yeah for the cubic
projection yes yes okay then why does
this not look distorted
and maybe I can't tell okay
can I get some texture is there a nice
grid texture what is a grid tape what's
a good texture that
if you go to the first uh this example
doesn't have that
um
well we change that on this page
normally the latest updates should have
a quick texture of um
now let's try to texture this I think
that that example there with a cube and
you see that the pattern shows exactly
what it does
no but I think we're going to so let's
say that you rotated that cube a little
bit it will start to look weird see what
I'm saying
ah look at this okay so this is this
version so that's orthogonal okay yeah
now let's try taking that same thing
oh my God my my um
what
something is very broken this is a yusu
problem that was that was the the um my
mouse got confused my mouse was captured
yes it was it was squeaking it was mouse
trap it was it was a mouse trap right
okay now let me understand this ah yes
those are distorted good
see what I'm saying yes that's what I
expected to see it's orthogonally
projected
from and you should use an example like
this because this is useful to see this
and if I show a tetrahedron here
there will be probably significant
distortion on some of these faces
surprised there isn't more distortion
do you see what I'm saying yeah because
there should be a
yeah go ahead I think that it's um
that's a pretty regular tetrahedron so
if it was like super
oh like one round of polyhedron let's
try random polyhedron
what's the argument to random polyhedron
the number of faces
oops
why didn't that work
um because doesn't just support that
options but it will right yep yes
where am I supposed to put this
don't you have design review somewhere I
do now yeah I thought I had a more
specific place but anyway
okay
um
all right we're late for another design
review I think but what else should I
see here particularly I mean this is
nice I think I understand what this is
doing
and now this new vertex texture
coordinates is a new Option or did we
already have that so we had it for
polygons and polyhedra
but those are the ones that are purely
defined by by vertices these other ones
are not so we're using it as a
placeholder and I suspect that maybe we
shouldn't call it vertex texture chord
just texture coordinates I think we
should call it texture well why don't we
call it texture coordinate system
or Texture should it should it be
texture mapping or
well has its your coordinate function
right
for plot functions
what do we have
I think what texture coordinates
function texture coordinate scaling or
plot functions
this is suffering slow
but that that sort of goes away
when the plot is done
I'm saying that's to handle the
construction
of the texture coordinates
uh
I mean there's a whole giant sort of set
of conventions about how you map random
you know lumps of texture onto random
surfaces and what you're doing here we
talked about this like two or three
years ago
is you're providing useful conventions
which is the right thing to do for the
different ways that you can map a
texture onto something yeah it's not the
end of the story but it's a very useful
step
right but all of these are single slab
mappings as in you're not tiling the
thing with this right you're just saying
yeah here's the thing and
you know so you're saying you've got one
you know what you're showing in these
pictures is you've got one slab of
texture
what do you do with it
right what's the difference in the Box
in the cubic
is the Box on all sides in the cubic is
only on three I don't understand that I
don't understand it either
12.
hello Charles
oh sorry I was mute I say yeah good
point I don't remember exactly what was
the difference now I should think about
it again do you remember
um kind of like a wall have the uh uh uh
the other side flipped
so like uh
uh extraction and negative X Direction
they are flipped or not okay well you
know what if that's the case you need to
have a better illustration because with
a square grid you can't tell if anything
is flipped
right you should put a letter or
something on the you know a t or an A or
something on those things to show that
even that wouldn't be obvious how it's
flipped but you obviously going to show
that it's flipped if it's flipped
okay okay now let's talk about what this
thing is this is a texture I agree it's
a texture mapping
I mean why isn't it really a texture
mapping and these are just named
versions of texture mapping
that's exactly what it is exactly that
then let's call it texture mapping
because that's you know that's a good
branded name and that's what it is and
these are some uh kind of
named versions of that maybe we should
call them projections like in in Geo we
call everything all the mappings
projections I know but we don't have a
texture there
they're not projections in that sense I
mean they're
it's
it's going the other way right
a projection is you have a thing that is
a sphere and you're going to render it
in in um uh
you know yeah Flats so this is inverse
projection
in that if you want to follow that
right
um
just a minute uh yes right but we
shouldn't call it inverse projection I
think texture mapping is a much better
and understood term for this sure
um
so I you know I recommend that I I think
texture mapping is good I mean one day
we might have more you know there are I
remember some seeing some catalog of uh
some years ago years ago
some why was I I actually watched some
talk about this by some
character well-known character I forgot
which which of the various Graphics
characters it was about all the
different ways one can do texture
mapping and and various kinds of
mathematical characterizations we talked
about that at that time and this is
basically just the named examples of
that which is a good place to start and
one day maybe texture mapping could have
as a right-hand side some other
mathematical specification but it's
clear that there is no obvious
completely uniform mathematical
specification because you know you're
mapping onto a triceratops or something
and it's you know it's just complicated
but I like what you're doing here wait
where you just say
this is the shape
on which the thing will appear I don't
understand this one for example I don't
understand spherical I don't understand
you know you've got a thing
that is basically a square right
and now there are different ways that
you can shine light through your Square
am I making sense but what is this here
and I understand stereographic but what
is this here is it using spherical
coordinates or what well what how does
it do that it's got a freaking Square
what is it doing is it a is it Phi and
Theta you know and for a speaker so
that's equirectangular coordinates
basically
is that right that's a projection
because in the spherical case right it's
got to define a projection it's got to
define the analog geoprojection which is
which it is then going to invert
it has to and maybe we should allow that
possibility I mean I think that would be
very cool if we could say you know and
we will need something like that maybe
for uh our Geographics 3D
can you comment on I mean right now the
spherical thing doesn't make any sense
it doesn't make sense I don't know what
it is
anybody comment on that I mean it's
presumably equally rectangular but we
don't know it doesn't say that
you Sue or anybody here
oh
okay you've got to think about it
well let's hear from it another time
here okay we gotta go to our other
meeting
so
thanks and I think there might be a very
brief if we can combine some of the
loose ends here with some other meeting
that we're doing some other design
review that will be good what did you
think we have left us Loose Ends
this thing spherical here
um okay just asking yeah that that's one
loose end
uh I'd like to see this actually working
um
these were just mostly finishing things
so very little in the way it Loose Ends
okay
all right thanks very much and uh see
Roger you're in the next design review
aren't you yep
which is about sound and vision now we
don't have that long for it but we'll
get what we can do done
okay
thanks a lot thanks to folks on the live
stream and we hope to see you in the
next
uh thing in just a couple minutes
okay bye for now